E aí
[Música]
o Olá meu nome é Jessé
Olá eu sou professor
bom e é claro que nessa oportunidade de
estar aqui no tédio não poderia deixar
de contar história de um garotinho
e Esse garotinho
ele era Neto de uma das primeiras
moradoras de uma das favelas mais
antigas aqui de Curitiba e
o porquê que eles essa família foi né
escolher esse lugar para estar morar e
chamar de só seu
eles Depois de alguns problemas e em
casa não consegui pagar o aluguel eles
tiveram que ir para Periferia lugar mais
longe que tem na cidade para encontrar
um lugar que antes não era ocupado
eu vou chamar de seu de alguma maneira
improvisada no primeiro momento mas
depois de maneira permanente
e é criar sua família
bom e ali do material reciclado que eles
transformavam em dinheiro para comprar
alimentos de vez em quando se sou brava
alguma melhoria no barraco
a eles ao longo do longo período de
tempo
existirão ações de despejo com muitos
tipos de violência preconceito
eu e nessa
é dessa maneira essa senhora criou seus
seis filhos e alguns dos seus netos
incluído Esse garotinho
o e viver na comunidade Ele conta que é
você tentar ser feliz com o que você tem
você joga bola na na rua solta pipa
brincar de esconde-esconde pelos becos
e da vizinhança
e pede um ingrediente de bolo para o
vizinho uma farinha o fermento e de
repente você é o suficiente para fazer
um bolo de fubá não deixa passar o
aniversário de ninguém da turma
é mas também
e pede encontrar o que se tem mais de
duro na vida é
E aí você perdeu o material da escola
móveis da casa
e as fotos da família nas enchentes do
rio
e também você perdeu um amigo
de maneira triste e violenta que ao
contrário do os móveis do material você
seco recupero
o amigo você não encontra mais para
conversar em dar risada
o e naquele momento se menino ele se
perguntava o
é porque eu nasci aqui ó
E por que que acontece isso comigo
o que não se tem amor
é o que eu olho para frente não vejo
nada
É nesse momento entendemos que o poeta
disse
e o que é o que é clara e salgada cabe
em um olho e pesa uma tonelada e
é mas como um farol
e a escola estava lá de alguma maneira
guiando
e iluminando a vida de muitas crianças
através da Educação
e foi lá que pela primeira vez ele ouviu
o elogio de uma pessoa
mãe Vista nesse menino ele é brilhante
e foi lá também que ele aprendeu que é
uma meta sonho
os alunos pega um pedaço de papel e
escreva um sonho que vocês têm
Oi e agora acreditem tanto nesse sonho
no tem tanto por esse sonho
ao ponto de Quando vocês acordarem a
única coisa que você tem que fazer é
caminhar por esse sonho
e essa história
é lá poderia ser das milhares de
crianças que ainda vivem nessas
condições
essa história essas lembranças são
minhas
ah e hoje eu acordei
pensando se a minha vó lá de cima ainda
tá me escutando se
e se me escutando ainda tá
o e olhando assim olhando ainda tá se
orgulhando
é mas ela viveu o suficiente para ver
muitos essa comunidade
tornarem pessoas boas lutarem
e por ter uma formação tem um trabalho
serem a gente transformação na sociedade
nós vivemos
o e
Engenheiro advogado
os profissionais da Saúde
ah e também
coletores de materiais reciclados
famosos tratadores nós conhecemos Percy
nome eles são agentes de transformação
socioambiental
bom e nós devemos muito a ele
Olá hoje nós temos uma estimativa que 90
noventa e cinco porcento dos material
reciclado é coletado é feito através do
trabalho dele
bom então depois
de muita luta
atravessar alguns Abismo SUS e muitas
barreiras
e eu tive oportunidade de me informar
hoje eu sou um arquiteto urbanista
pesquisador
e e tenta estar próximo da ciência
Oi Que pegou maneiro queria a resposta
às minhas perguntas mas está próximo da
ciência na verdade vou te dar mais
pergunta é
o e
novamente já tem uma estimativa que até
noventa e cinco porcento da população
mundial estará vivendo nos grandes
centros urbanos gente vai precisar de
mais moradias mas transporte público
mas espaço de qualidade para fazer mais
hospitais
sim mas mais oportunidade
vamos continuar impactando no meio
ambiente onde vivemos ao mesmo tempo que
eu meio ambiente impacta quem vive nele
e quando a gente percebe as vezes a
gente não percebe né como esse ambiente
tá em Porto nossa vida e às vezes a
gente percebe muito nesse ano
- 15° do Brasil sensação térmica de
menos 15 graus
ah e também é poder olhar na cidade de
uma outra maneira
Olá estou participando de uma pesquisa
estamos tentando entender como o meio e
o meio urbano está embarcando da Saúde
Mental das pessoas
Oi e esse primeira etapa dessa pesquisa
já trouxe um dado extremamente
interessante
Os
estudantes meninas
ela chegou muito mais ansiosas E
estressadas na escola do que os meninos
o porquê
é só que a gente nunca percebeu isso
ou será que a gente está tentando pensar
em uma maneira que nossa cidade surgiu
mais inclusivas
especialmente para as mulheres
e as mulheres se sentem
tranquilas em estar em todos os lugares
e ocupar todos os espaços
Ah e outra maneira que eu tenho tentado
retribuir o que eu recebi
vou voltar para escola voltei pra escola
e lá na escola eu tenho essa
oportunidade de estar com os alunos
é de poder
experimentar comecei a professor do
Brasil que não é fácil pouco
reconhecimento o salário baixo às vezes
muito insatisfeito às vezes muito
satisfeito
a perguntas do tipo professor se eu não
vier na sexta-feira você me dá faltas
o professor você trabalha ou só dá aula
é mas também é importante levar essas
questões que a ciência nos dá para ele
alunos O quê que vocês vem lá fora o que
pode ser mudado
O que podemos fazer
eu sou muito criativos muito
inteligentes
e Mais especificamente um dia um grupo
de alunos me diz
o professor nessa noite morador de rua
morreu de frio aqui em Curitiba acho que
podemos fazer alguma coisa
tô pensando hoje nisso
e eu fico tentando entender Em que
momento
e a gente fez aquele Clique na nossa
consciência e deixou de olhar para essa
situação
a gente começou a a olhar para uma
pessoa que está na calçada e achar que
não ornamento do cenário Urbano que nós
vivemos
e também certeza que nós em algum
momento também já tivemos essa mesma
percepção desse aluno desses alunos
É mas não vamos tem que seguir a vida
sem estudar tem que trabalhar desde que
alguém vai resolver eu vai ajudar não é
problema seu
e esse essa
percepção
especificamente desses alunos se
transformou em um projeto
o quê
e de alguma maneira
e não vai acabar com esse desafio que
nós temos nos centros urbanos
é mas poderia e muito
a
diminuir o sofrimento dessas pessoas
E aí
oi oi
e
ali nós temos em torno de 200 caixinhas
de leite nessa parte da gente utiliza aí
nosso dia a dia essa Coitada aqui já
sabe utilizado a gente fez ainda antes
da pandemia e abrimos ela E fechamos
óleo mas tem vejo
o projeto que ele foi reconhecido
nacional e internacionalmente já tivemos
muitos prêmios por cima de muitas feiras
de estação científica
é mas realmente a lógica nunca feia
é a nossa intenção sempre foi quê
a esses alunos criassem um senso de
humanidade
é um senso de comunidade
é mostrar que a ciência lá no se trata
de Descoberto mas sim de mudança na vida
das pessoas
I e II
e agora gostaria de propor um
um
pequeno exercício de reflexão
o quê que vocês vem lá fora
E aí
o que pode ser feito lá fora
e
como podemos criar oportunidade na vida
de alguém
E aí
Bom dia nesse momento
e nós percebemos que realmente o que
muda o mundo serão as perguntas
é obrigado a